good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight a historic moment today in the
world of politics after much trial and
error and a great deal of anxiety and
frustrated harrumphing on cable news
panels the Democratic establishment
tonight finally has chosen a candidate
to stop Bernie Sanders before he can
take their money there's much relief in
Washington right now
the Sanders threat is imminent and
profound and they've been sweating it
imagine general Chinese Gordon
surrounded by screaming Mahdi's at the
siege of Khartoum and you will know how
they feel terrified it's one thing if
your country falls apart if tenth
graders can't read and nine-year-olds
are taking puberty blocking drugs and
downtown LA looks like Calcutta and
another 10,000 more Americans just out
of fentanyl overdose whatever Americans
are dying Democrats are fine with that
they can live with it they do they don't
say a word but if there's a rogue
candidate out there who might actually
be serious about closing the carried
interest loophole and forcing private
equity barons to pay the same effective
tax rate that you do well that cannot
stand it's totally and completely
unacceptable in fact it's morally wrong
alert the panel on Morning Joe or going
to war and tonight they have found their
war horse a hero they imagine will carry
them forth to victory against the wild
haired infidel from Vermont it is this
candidate whom you should know is
literally now the youngest man in the
Democratic race this is the man they
believe has the competence the intensity
the intellect to repel the seething
horde of Sanders i'ts ladies and
gentlemen mr. Joe Biden book tomorrow's
superstar Suze and I want to thank you
all I tell you what I'm rushing ahead on
a hundred and fifty million people have
been killed since 2007 when Bernie voted
to exempt the gun manufacturers from
liability it would put 720 million vak
million women back in the workforce
nobody should be in jail for a
non-violent crime my name is Joe Biden
I'm a Democratic candidate for the
United States Senate what's not to like
about form on terms the beauty of it and
what a neat town way the radio make sure
the television
they excuse me make sure you have the
record player on at night poor kids are
just as bright and just as talons white
kids we choose science over fiction we
choose truth over facts think about it
we hold these truths to be self-evident
all men are women created by goal you
know that you know the thing yep
that's the man it's super Thursday and
he's running for the United States
Senate in memory of the nearly half the
country that's murdered by guns in the
last few years
guided by the belief that other children
as bright and talented as white kids not
to mention clean inarticulate and in the
hope that he can put three-quarters of a
billion women back to work whether they
want to go or not if that's the kind of
transformational candidate you're
looking for Joe Biden is your man or if
he lookin for someone to get you a
second serving of jell-o from the 430
early bird buffet Biden could do that
too he's a Renaissance man it was he
himself will tell you the Renaissance
was an awful long time ago back during
the Carter Administration actually and
you know what Jimmy was a good guy
better than they said and so on honestly
and how do you say this without being
rude or mean this whole thing is sad
worse than that it's cruel running Joe
Biden for president is like making your
dog wear a dress it may make for an
amusing Instagram post but it's wrong
you can see the confusion in the dog's
eyes you can see the same thing in Joe
Biden's eyes if you look closely why am
I here what are we talking about maybe
if I make a lot of noise about push-ups
no one will notice so far the only thing
we've learned from Biden's candidacy is
that there's no one around him who cares
enough to make him stop instead there
are only enablers today both Pete Buddha
judge and Amy Klobuchar endorsed by
denoted former Senate Majority Leader
Harry Reid and beta or Roarke these are
party people doing the bidding of their
corporate masters there's nothing warm
or sentimental about it they're pushing
a defective product on consumers and
they know it
there's someone lawn darts but whatever
it takes the Biden campaign isn't about
ideas much less ideals the Democratic
establishments only concern is
institutional control that's where all
of their power comes from from holding
together and running things if the
Democratic coalition breaks down they
are by definition
powerless they have nothing and the real
threat of Bernie Sanders is the threat
he poses to the party he could split it
in half and break it forever that cannot
happen Joe Biden is their last chance
that's why they're backing him how about
the only group sincerely cheering Biden
on tonight are the credit card companies
for decades Biden was their paid Lackey
in Washington they bribed him with cash
they gave jobs to his son in return he
carried their legislation through
Congress dutifully for many many years
meanwhile untold Americans average joe's
as Joe himself likes to say were crushed
by credit card debt the average credit
card interest rate in this country is
twenty one percent twenty one percent
interest at a time when the Fed is
giving banks billions of dollars nearly
for free that's how low interest rates
are for them but you're paying 21
percent this is a disaster how bad is it
let's put it in perspective ask yourself
how many people do you know personally
who've been hospitalized for coronavirus
something we're all worried about
unjustly maybe none now ask yourself how
many people you know personally whose
lives have been been diminished or
destroyed by credit card debt yeah maybe
it's happened to you it probably has
it's happened to so many people Joe
Biden is one of the decision makers who
made that possible that's not an
overstatement but they don't care now
they're telling you that for the good of
the country you've got to vote for Joe
Biden keep in mind they don't even
believe it as they say it they don't
even like Biden but at this point
they'll say anything because they have
to